all right zach
zach where'd you grow up where are you
from originally i'm from boston
massachusetts and holly i'm 20 years old
20. i turned 20 in august happy birthday
thank you a little bit late um tell me
about your family growing up you had mom
and dad yeah both my parents my mom's
italian and my dad's african
so
yeah but my mom's like my best friend i
love her so much and my dad he's great
and they've always been so accepting of
me and who i am i've had i've had a good
childhood like there were ups and downs
but
overall it was pretty good do you feel
loved by your family your parents yeah i
feel really loved and accepted my
brother is also queer like me so i felt
like it was kind of hard for my parents
to deal with that but they've been the
most supportive especially my dad she's
been so supportive with me and like they
support everything i do you're so lucky
and you're going to school here in new
york city yeah i go to the school in
marymount manhattan where are you
studying i'm studying fashion marketing
of course you are
look at you um
so you i met you in washington square
park
which is a fun little park for kids like
you to hang out in um
how do you like new york city you've
been here for how long a year probably
yeah i came last august so yeah like a
year yeah and i love it because like
before new york i felt like i was more
just like
hiding myself i was like basic some
would say but like moving to new york i
really started to like
find myself and explore like my gender
expression i see a lot of young people
like yourself who just seem so free
to be whoever they want yeah i feel like
i dropped like dead weight when i left
home you can express yourself however
you feel like it no one's judging you no
one's giving you a hard time yeah
there's so many types of people here and
i love that especially in washington
square park where you'll see everything
from the heroin dealers in the northwest
corner to the people playing chess and
taking
their kids and people to the dancing
yeah there's everything here absolutely
and uh your friends that you've made
here or friends you brought from boston
or yeah i have friends that go to my
school i also model and do drag so i met
friends through there
so you have an interesting mix of things
going on yeah
what's the most difficult aspect of
living in new york
i'd say being away from your family
yeah being away from my family is hard
but like i guess that's just like a part
of life i don't know i'd say like the
most difficult part of being in new york
is kind of just like
everything is like
everything moves really fast and it's
easy to feel alone even surrounded by a
bunch of people
and like it just gets hard sometimes
because sometimes i feel like i am alone
here and like everything like none of my
dreams are going to come true and like
it's really so far out but then i just
like snap myself out of that yeah no new
york's a very inspiring city for
creatives yeah and there's so many other
creative and so many people just like
you so it's like hard to stand out but i
just convinced myself like i'm me so
whatever happens yeah but if you can if
you put yourself back in boston
that becomes a difficult environment for
fashion
yeah i felt like there is like i don't
hate where i came from but i felt like
there was like nothing there for me no
boston's a great city but yeah but for
fashion it's probably not going to be
not going to happen as easily it might
in new york but there's tons of
competition here yeah a lot of
competition yeah
and but you're so close to home which is
great yeah it's only like five hour four
hour drive yeah not so bad
and where so where are you staying which
part of the city um i'm like the lower
east side like right by east village
and you've been around manhattan you've
seen the different neighborhoods and
stuff like that yeah i've been around it
i haven't been like exploring it like i
haven't seen like everything because
like last year with covey like i wasn't
really going out that much i was kind of
just like stuck in my dorm yeah but i'm
starting to see more and more i've seen
a lot of brooklyn so far yeah and your
classes are
in person or online i have a few in
person a few online so
like a few days during the week i travel
and then the rest are online yeah
what do you do for fun here you are at
night and
yeah i recently started like going to
the club scene and doing drag which i
found so fun and so freeing because that
was something i was never like i didn't
think i could do back home i didn't
think think i could ever achieve that
and like drag is just like i found is
one of my passions like modeling like it
makes me like feel so confident and like
i can just like make my inner fantasy
come true and like
new york and the nightlife helped me
find that and and
how do you
identify what do you call yourself you
are
no you're not trans are you i'm not
trans but i do fall into like the
non-binary range like i i use my
pronouns like he she or they like i
don't really mind because in my head i
feel like gender is like a construct
it's like made like sex is like
something that's real like the genitals
you're born with is real but gender
gender roles is something that's created
by society and i like it made me feel
trapped for so long and then once i like
let that go and like didn't put barriers
of what i could do because i'm like a
boy i was so much more happier there's
one one thing i've noticed in new york
especially on this trip is how many
young people
are like yourself where they're just
blending the
the lines of what
is male female yeah and it's always
existed and now people are like feeling
more comfortable to like show it show it
and that's beautiful yeah it really is
it's it's
it's nice that people
are free to do whatever they want to do
and new york's a perfect environment to
do that yeah gender is a construct and
when you tear that apart
yeah no it in
so you you'll have romantic
relationships with men or female
um
i feel like i'm attracted to men or like
masculine presenting people but i don't
like to put like a barrier of what like
i like or what i don't like if i find
myself attracted to somebody i'm gonna
go for it it doesn't matter what
what what they are yeah i don't like to
like put a barrier around myself because
like you never know
uh so did do you feel like this was
something you were just you were born
this way or something happened to you as
a child or anything like that or
what led you down this path
i feel like i was born this like way
like how i am and i feel like it was
just like for so long like it was just
like pushed to the side like i didn't
want to embrace my feminine i didn't
want to embrace like the other parts of
me so for so long i just presented
myself in a certain way and then like i
just realized like this is who i am i
can't change it so might as well just
work with what i got and do what makes
me feel happy yeah and to be hiding it
in boston or wherever else you might
live
must be very frustrating
yeah it was frustrating because i would
like hide who i was but like
like me toned down hiding what i was
wasn't even i wasn't hiding it to
anybody right so like yeah i would
people would say things to me like i
wasn't like viciously bullied but like
people would say things to me i always
felt like
i felt like i was gonna like when i was
growing up like in middle school i felt
like i was like a grown-up with like a
bunch of kids like i felt like i grew up
really quick because like i feel like i
saw the harsh sides of the world because
like the girlfriends i had wouldn't get
treated the same way i did and like the
privileges they got i wouldn't get
yeah it's got to be difficult
that our world is changing it is
changing and i'm happier for the newer
generation growing up that they're going
to be able to explore like who they are
younger in life instead of finding out
so late it's interesting interesting how
sexuality i guess is changing and and
the lines are getting blurred and
changed and you know kind of like how
race
became like you know it was black or
white and then that that got blurred
very quickly yeah because who needs all
these labels yeah the labels are just
causing more problems than they sell
yeah it's like not beneficial for anyone
to like just be put in one certain box
yeah where do you see your life going as
you get older what do you like to do do
you have dreams of
i i have like a passion for like high
fashion so i see myself like on runways
doing campaigns for like dior savage
xfenty with rihanna and also like going
higher in my drag like elevating that
and like modeling in my drag and like
being able to perform for
people because i love to perform and
like hype up a crowd and stuff
so i just like exploring like i just see
myself like getting more and more
creative like finding out how to elevate
my modeling finding out how to elevate
my drag
yeah and and new york city is the
perfect place to do all that yeah it's
literally the perfect place for all of
you to imagine another city better
they're better than here to do it yeah
and i'm here for school but like i'm
also here because like to find like do
my dreams yeah did you see yourself
staying here after you get out of school
yes we're gonna go
i don't know where else to go
but i do want to travel and like
but hopefully i can get these
opportunities and travel with that but
yeah
i definitely want to like
relocate eventually
see like la see like places like that
like we're also like
fashion and like modeling is important
there too yeah well you're just 19. yeah
you're 20 right yeah 20. yeah you're 20.
so you you'll you'll figure this out in
the next you'll change your mind five
times the next five yeah i love new york
but the one thing i don't really like
not a fan of like i'm more of like a
nature person like i like to go and hike
because i like to like do all that and
like
go to the lake and stuff because like i
have a lake house yeah what you have in
boston yeah so i don't really like i'm
not really a fan of like the cityscape
type but
yeah washington square park is about as
much nature's nature yeah when i see
trees around here i'm like oh my god is
that a tree yeah
no but new york's a really fun city in
every other way
yeah it's so fun yeah
what to
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your 20 years
what do you what do you what do you try
to live by
well i think i said this before but what
i try to live by is that like i'm me i
can't change that because i go through
times where i'm like really insecure and
i hate myself like i don't think i'm
good enough i don't think i'm worthy of
love but then i realized that like
i'm me like i can't change that like i
could i can't change who i am i can't
change my soul like i can change my
outer appearance but i can't like change
who i am and like with fashion like
that's why i like love fashion so much
because it's like
how i present myself is like a lot of
times how i get up in the morning like
back when i didn't like in high school
like i hated high school but the only
thing that got me up was like getting
ready like putting on an outfit that
made me feel confident so like yeah
excellent
thank you so much for sharing your story
zach
thank you i wish you the best of luck
thank you whatever you do thank you
you